[Applause]
this is an equipment graveyard
it's a typical final resting place for
medical equipment from hospitals in
africa
now why is this most of the medical
devices used in africa
are imported and quite often they're not
suitable for local conditions
they may require trained staff that
aren't available to operate and maintain
and repair them they may not be able to
withstand
high temperatures and humidity and they
usually require
a constant and reliable supply of
electricity
an example of a medical device that may
have ended up
in an equipment graveyard at some point
is an ultrasound monitor to track the
heart rate
of unborn babies this is the standard of
care
in rich countries in low resource
settings
the standard of care is often a midwife
listening to the baby's heart rate
through a horn
now this approach has been around for
more than a century
it's very much dependent on the skill
and the experience of the midwife
two young inventors from uganda visited
an
antenatal clinic at a local hospital a
few years ago
when they were students in information
technology
they noticed that quite often the
midwife was not able to hear
any heart rate when listening trying to
listen to it through this horn
so they invented their own fetal heart
rate monitor
they adapted the horn and connected it
to a smartphone
an app on the smartphone records the
heart rate
analyzes it and provides the midwife
with a range of information
on the status of the baby
these inventors are called aaron tushave
and joshua o'kello another inventor
tender kai katsiga was working for an
ngo in botswana that manufactured
hearing aids
now he noticed that these hearing aids
needed batteries that needed replacement
very often at a cost that was not
affordable
for most of the users that he knew now
in response
and being an engineer tendikai invented
a solar-powered battery charger with
rechargeable batteries that could be
used in these hearing aids
he co-founded a company called
deathtronics
which now manufactures the solar ear
which is a hearing aid powered by his
invention
my colleague sudesh sivarasu
invented a smart glove for people who
have suffered from leprosy
even though their disease may have been
cured the resulting nerve damage
will have left many of them without a
sense of touch in their hands
this puts them at risk of injury
the glove has sensors to detect
temperature and pressure
and warn the user it effectively serves
as an artificial sense of touch
and prevents injury sudesh invented this
glove
after observing former leprosy patients
as they carried out their day-to-day
activities and he learnt about the risks
and the hazards in their environment
now the inventors that i've mentioned
integrated engineering with healthcare
this is what biomedical engineers do
at the university of cape town we run a
course called health innovation and
design
it's taken by many of our graduate
students in biomedical engineering the
aim of the course
is to introduce these students to the
philosophy of the design world
the students are encouraged to engage
with communities as they search for
solutions to health related problems
one of the communities that we work with
is a group of elderly people in cape
town
a recent class project had the task of
addressing hearing loss in these elderly
people
the students many of them being
engineers set out
believing that they would design a
better hearing aid
they spent time with the elderly chatted
to their healthcare providers
and their caregivers they soon realized
that
actually adequate hearing aids already
existed
but many of the elderly who needed them
and had access to them
didn't have them and many of those who
had hearing aids
wouldn't wear them the students realized
that many of these elderly people were
in denial of their hearing loss
there's a stigma attached to wearing a
hearing aid
they also discovered that the
environment in which these elderly
people lived
did not accommodate their hearing loss
for example
their homes and then community centre
were filled with echoes that interfered
with their hearing
so instead of developing and designing a
new and better hearing aid
the student did an audit of the
environment with a view to improving the
acoustics
they also devised a campaign to raise
awareness of hearing loss
and to counter the stigma attached to
wearing a hearing aid
now this often happens when one pays
attention to the user
in this case the elderly and their needs
and their context
one often has to move away from the
focus of technology and reformulate the
problem
now this approach to understanding a
problem through listening and engaging
is not new but it often isn't followed
by engineers who are intent
on developing technology
one of our students has a background in
software engineering
he had often created products for
clients that the client ultimately did
not like
when a client would reject a product it
was common at his company
to proclaim that the client just didn't
know what they wanted
having completed the course the student
fed back to us
that he now realized that it was he who
hadn't understood what the client wanted
another student student gave us feedback
that she had learned to design with
empathy
as opposed to designing for
functionality which is what our
engineering education had taught her
so what all of this illustrates us that
is that we often blinded to real needs
in our pursuit of technology but we need
technology
we need hearing aids we need fetal heart
rate monitors
so how do we create more medical device
success stories
from africa how do we create more
inventors
rather than relying on a few exceptional
individuals
who are able to perceive real needs and
respond in ways than work
well we focus on needs and people and
context
but this is obvious you might say of
course context is important
but africa is a diverse continent with
vast
disparities in health and wealth and
income and education
if we assume that our engineers and
inventors
already know enough about the different
african contexts
to be able to solve the problems of our
different communities and our most
marginalized communities then we might
get it wrong
but then if we on the african continent
don't
necessarily know enough about it then
perhaps anybody with the right level of
skill and commitment
could fly in spend some time listening
and engaging
and fly out knowing enough to invent for
africa
but understanding context is not about a
superficial interaction
it's about deep engagement and an
immersion
in the realities and the complexities of
our context
and we in africa are already immersed
we already have a strong and rich base
of knowledge
from which to start finding solutions to
our own problems
so let's not rely too much on others
when we live on a continent that is
filled with untapped talent
thank you